oh and Solon Castle is a popular motif
for photographers not just for tourists
but for locals as well like this soccer
team from nearby Stein - steeple console
indeed for us hohenzollern castle is
part of hawing about half a million
tourists come here but we have it on our
doorstep the 19th century castle has
served as a backdrop for Hollywood films
it sits atop that solar berg like a
gothic fortress the Hohenzollerns
certainly built themselves an impressive
structure thus pizanno von teese Ibaka
sees I'm not soon Alice when special
about this castle is that it's a
national cultural monument because it's
the ancestral castle of the House of
Hohenzollern the family of hereditary
oppression hence German kings and
emperors it attracts visitors from
around the world I love it here
unlocking inside the castle you can find
out more about the Hohenzollern dynasty
among the most famous members of the
family Prussian King Frederick the Great
and the last german emperor wilhelm ii
the castle is still owned by the horn
salons in the entrance hall with its
painted family tree you see the family
members who were born more recently like
George Frederick Prince of Prussia it's
here you see chart Fredrik five years
ago he married the daughter of a German
called Princess Sophie from Eisenberg
beer stein and he's the head of the
family right now
there are special tours for children
with costumes to wear and chainmail they
can touch
if you like you can take it in two hands
to feel the weight very strong I know
draw it so heavy it weighs about six
kilos the Treasury contains valuable
items belonging to the family like the
dented snuff box that belonged to
Frederick the Great it saved his life
when a bullet lodged in it here set with
gemstones and pearls is the crown of the
last German emperor there's also a beer
garden hoe and Solon Castle is a popular
venue for engagement and wedding parties
like this couple from China what do they
and their friends think about the castle